it's great to welcome Finn brunt into
the program today who's an associate
professor in media culture and
communication at New York University so
great to talk to you Finn thank you so
much for having me David so I I want to
eventually talk about some of the
different sort of money related
movements that are going on right now
you have some countries increasingly
going cashless you have cryptocurrency
and all of that movement entails but to
go back a little bit there may be a lot
of people in our audience who don't know
sort of the history of non-physical cash
payments when I think about that I first
think of sort of like credit that was
kept on a ledger was the first form of
like a non-cash payment but how should
we sort of conceive of that that's a
really good way of looking at it
actually we tend to think about money as
something like cash but if you want to
actually go back into the history of it
most of money for all of human history
has been debt and credit that's been
recorded on Ledger's on tablets on
papyrus that's been circulated in a lot
of different ways and indeed a lot of
the money that exists now even though
again if I were to you know Google money
the image that would come up would be a
pile of cash is actually again Ledger's
systems of credit and debt just that
they're electronic now yes so I guess
when did that transition start to happen
so certainly like a paper ledger at the
blacksmith shop is not digital cash in
the sense that we now sort of think
about it but the idea of the money being
ones and zeros in a bank account credit
cards and other forms of digital cash
how far back does that go that goes back
quite a ways actually like I was really
surprising length of time we tend to
think about these things as being very
recent you know we talked about crypto
currencies as though they like fell out
of the cargo bay of a UFO like all at
once you know a decade ago but the
history of electronic money like banks
have been on this for decades and
decades and decades right like they want
to have settlement systems that can work
fast that are reliable they already had
most of their sense of what money is in
the form of writing something down in
one document and transferring it to
another document so we can see
mechanisms ranging from like in turbine
settlement to cashing checks a lot of
these things have been electronic for a
long time but it was only in the 1970s
that people began to realize that this
kind of money electronic money digital
money ones and zeros as you say is going
to be everybody's money soon and that
that was a major social problem so now I
think that there's the idea that many
hold that cryptocurrency in its current
form is completely unique as a
phenomenon and in a sense I mean Bitcoin
is a relatively new thing specifically
but some of the the precedent for
Bitcoin like mechanisms do date back to
the 70s as you're talking about don't
they yes oh yeah absolutely
partially because people well maybe a
good way to put this is that when we
talk about a technology like Bitcoin
we're actually talking about something
that has a couple of different agendas
that it's trying to serve and when we
look at where digital cash stuff came
from we basically see those different
agendas at work so the earliest forms of
the underlying technologies that
eventually fed into Bitcoin where
digital cash projects that were just
designed to protect privacy they weren't
designed to like create a new form of
money they weren't designed to
necessarily let you do all of the you
know groovy new cryptocurrency stuff
people do now instead it was just a way
to say I want to exchange money with you
I want to buy something from you I want
to receive a gift from you that will
function like cash so that it will
create no record of the transaction
between us it will not need to know
anything about our identities it will
not enable any form of surveillance or
control to happen for that transaction
and so that's what we first see is the
idea of digital cash should be a
mechanism for protecting privacy when I
look at the sort of genesis of the
earlier forms of digital cash and also
more recently the cryptocurrency
movement it seems that there may be this
is a little bit too simplistic but there
are sort of two political ideologies
that seem to be particularly interested
there's the sort of libertarian side
which is about removing the government
as an intermediary privacy
direct transactions rather than the
intermediate you know intermediated
transactions and sort of like when you
look at Peter Thiel who was involved
with PayPal who talked about well maybe
PayPal could even actually develop a
currency that is free from government in
one sense that's the libertarian side I
also see and I'm curious whether you
agree there's the sort of like techno
utopian side which is just about aside
from government and privacy and all of
these other elements there's the
technology is just going to make
everything better side question one is
do you agree that those are sort of the
two political wings that seem most
interested number two are there others
and is there overlap between those two
those are excellent questions yeah I
think I think they I think the answer to
both is yes with question one obviously
one of the most kind of complicated
legacies of the way the digital cash
came to be that still shapes a lot of
aspects of how Bitcoin works a lot of
those technology decisions and a lot of
the kind of culture that still takes
place in the cryptocurrency space was
this interweaving of the libertarian
side and as you say like the techno
utopian side and the libertarian side
has its own very specific way of looking
at digital cash which is a view of the
world which is deeply suspicious of the
notion that the government should have
the right to mint money and therefore we
need alternative currencies that tend be
as robust and reliable as something
issued by a central bank like with that
same level of like I trust that when I
receive this I know what it is I can
verify that it's real but with
additional elements that are really
important to libertarian ideology like
the idea that the currency should
function in a way that's more like a
precious metal you know it should it
should be issued in ways that become
steadily more difficult rather than mild
inflation to boost the economy but
there's also the techno utopian side
which is you know is often kind of
overlaps with libertarianism but which
has in some ways a deeper attitude which
is what if we could by changing the way
that money were
so what if we could unlock extraordinary
new levels of innovation if we could
change how markets work if we could
change how the circulation of assets
works what if that could be a spur to a
whole new level of investment and
invention and transformation and new
businesses and new ideas and as you say
like technology plus money would equal
better produce the kind of world of
breakthroughs that we might be hoping
for so those two are still by far the
the kind of most significant legacies
that shape cryptocurrency however there
have always been lots of other
interested parties who might want to
figure out how these things work and
they're more and more coming to the fore
and starting to shape some of the future
of these technologies so in particular
we can look at the way that a lot of
marginalized groups are very poorly
served by the current money system
whether we look at people who are
undocumented and have to live outside of
the normal banking apparatus if we look
at people who are in poverty really good
people are on food stamps like accessing
and interacting with cash is very
expensive but it's also extraordinarily
difficult unless you're a person above a
certain social stratum to get any kind
of access to credit or any kind of
access to normal banking yes systems
that are alternatives for that just as
their systems that could be alternatives
to the incredibly predatory system for
sending remittances for workers who are
working overseas those things are life
changing opportunities and they have
nothing to do with that kind of
libertarian excuse me that kind of
libertarian techno utopian legacy so
being able to see how those groups are
starting to move in I think that shows
us part of where cryptocurrency is going
yeah I mean I think what you're pointing
out is interesting which is that on the
one hand there are lots of currently
underserved populations by the system
that we have at the same time when
you're talking about technology that
requires some kind of physical hardware
and also sort of like the wherewithal in
terms of what your your awareness is you
I also have concerns
that going cashless at least in the
current way that it's happening in many
countries is also not particularly good
for some of those underserved
populations so I guess the question is
how to implement something like that a
move away from cash that will not
particularly hamper those underserved
populations that were sort of trying to
help at least in some circles oh yeah
absolutely
and that's that's a really good way of
looking at it too which is that there's
there's a lot of ways in which the
transition into a cashless or at least
less cash society would she could could
be could be a disaster right like
there's there's a lot of different ways
that that could play out there's many if
you'll forgive me being a little
hyperbolic there's a lot of like hungry
wolves out there who have been waiting
for the moment when the transaction
stream right when the data about
transactions and payments finally gets
folded into all of the other
surveillance data because the moment you
do that you can start doing all kinds of
other things which are deeply
discriminatory and predatory you can
start doing things like you know
real-time price fixing and redlining we
already see versions of that in our
ordinary lives right like you will get
different prices for airline tickets
based on what the Airlines server knows
about you based on the browser and the
computer that you're using right if
you're like trying to buy these tickets
with a browser that carries information
on suggest that you're using a more
expensive computer you have more money
to work with you're going to get a
different price
imagine that applied more generally to
every aspect of our lives imagine a
system where the platform has the
payment platform has sweetheart deals
with other companies which when we look
at something like Libra when we look at
something like all the various pies that
Peter Thiel has his fingers in would not
be a huge surprise so now imagine the
payment platform has sweetheart deals
with other companies and suddenly your
money is worth more or less depending on
whose products you're buying you're
being like steered in different
directions this is a dystopian future
and it's one that we should bear in mind
as as the the worst possible outcome
that could come from the effort that we
would make
to create new forms of credit and money
that were meant to originally help the
disadvantaged so we need to think very
carefully about not to defend Airlines I
believe they've denied that that type of
information is used to affect pricing I
believe they claim what is obvious which
is that there's a demand based system
which does fluctuate pricing based on
how many days until the flight and what
time of day and day of the week you are
looking but I believe they have in the
same way that Amazon has denied that
they are using so-called like
demographic data but this certainly the
assertion is there and you have restated
it here when it comes to Bitcoin or some
of the other current crypto currencies
specifically do these seem like these
are going to be the long-term
replacements for cash or do they seem
more like intermediate experiments and
that the solution is ultimately going to
be elsewhere that's a really good
question um if I were to bet and I think
this is a pretty reasonable bet I think
we're entering an era of much more
diverse forms and types of money I think
we're going to see not a sort of one
ring to rule them all you know single
fixed solution that replaces everything
instead we're going to see a
proliferation of different kinds of
vehicles that can range from well to put
it in actually very straightforward
terms we can all relate to we're already
starting to live in that world because
we're starting to live in a world that's
shaped so much by points right like so
many of us are now used to the idea that
we have cards or accounts that carry
different kinds of value on them some of
which can be redeemed for cash some of
which can be redeemed for miles some of
which can be redeemed for minutes
depending on what country you're in and
what circumstances you're under so what
we are already kind of surrounded by
there's a much more diverse money system
that we don't necessarily think of as
being diverse than just cash and credit
and that's just going to become much
more so we're going to see a lot more
specialized types of money and types of
currency for different populations and
different groups so it's going to be
really interesting to see how that plays
out because I suspect that we will start
to understand ourselves as living in an
ecosystem of money all right
then Brunton doing an extremely good job
of keeping his cat out of the shot I can
tell the state behind the door Ben is an
associate professor of media culture and
communication at New York University
I've been really a pleasure speaking
with you today thank you so much David